i took the very best selling shoe and
said okay you can take all of these i
want this and i want a 10 royalty
because i'm about to be on tv
and then when it got on tv when i got
when when robin big hit mtv
like then everything all my signature
products exploded but that shoe that i
knew was already
uh going to be a huge seller then i made
you know i was making four or five
million a year off just that one just a
shoe yeah what about the tv show was the
tv show uh big it's mtv i don't think
they pay huge well no in the beginning i
was getting like you know i don't know
15 grand an episode season one you know
what i mean
yeah like you're not paying like
especially back then you're not paying
like two first-time random people
but that was and you and it was at your
uh in your in your warehouse no that was
in my house robin big was at my house
and you got look i saw what happened and
who are the other guys it was just
myself uh big black my cousin and then
two of big big blacks friends and our
dog meaty
uh but i'm you gotta understand at that
time i saw what happened to bam
margera's signature product
uh from being on jackass right so it had
just i don't know what happened with it
it exploded like he was like selling
more product than any other skateboarder
there was without being necessarily like
a top-tier pro skater so
when i
renegotiated before the show launched i
renegotiated all of my deals for higher
royalties and lower
uh set fees right and then i just made
millions when the show exploded i bet on
myself that this platform would do it so
then okay i made millions off of of my
signature products when i did fantasy
factory which was your place you bought
you bought a warehouse this is my
warehouse i had in downtown
they at the time then they're like you
know we'll give you 125 grand episode to
either do a fourth season of robin big
or your own show
so i wrote my own show and said the only
way i would do it if i own the
integrated marketing so then i now own
the platform so then i sold millions and
millions of dollars of deals to
microsoft and chevy and monster and dc
and everything wait the sales department
gave you the
the integration because they didn't it
was still a little early they didn't it
was still this gray area where nobody it
was before sort of bethany frankel's
like skinny girl and like the jersey
shore came out and all them it was right
before all that so i was able to own it
contractually
so i was now selling my own air time for
millions of dollars that mtv had no
control over right and but that you
didn't get uh uh pushback from the sales
department
because i own the rights i wouldn't do
it was in contractually i own the rights
but say i'm just throwing out a a a name
say ford you've got to deal with ford
and you're gonna i didn't deal with
chevy okay i i was the only person ever
to flip a car barrel roll car ramp to
ramp on a front-wheel drive car it was
for
the season premiere of season three of
fantasy factory and a super bowl
commercial and i sold all of that
directly to chevy not okay and they paid
you right what i'm saying is at the
network
the the sales department then does that
not close the door to them to fort you
know would this ford want to have a
commercial on a show that is flipping a
chevy no right so you're you're tying
the hands of the sales department and
the whole way that a network makes money
is by selling advertising correct so
they kind of changed the rule because
you can't do that anymore they don't
know the integration so you they change
the rules because of you yeah i'm saying
like like i was the last person to slip
it in there because they were like the
way i did the contract too is like if it
was integrated into the story of the
show
and then i had 100 approval of the
integration of the story into the show
and so
i but i also said hey if you guys want
me to create a show for something
we can do that too so they were like all
right it felt like a give and take only
unless the you know they would come to
me without someone unless they wanted to
pay me on the side i would say no not do
it i would only do deals with people
that paid me first and then if they
wanted to do a deal with the network
second they could do that you know wow
so you probably made a fortune on that
show i did why'd you stop doing the show
oh i mean it's just i mean you know i
was getting the attack by tigers and
getting towed into waves and breaking
world records jumping cars backwards it
was like so stunt intensive and
and just you know
it would take me six months to shoot 10
episodes where it takes me you know
you know a few hours to shoot six
episodes today for something like
ridiculousness you know so you just felt
like so but you so you ended it not the
network yeah well i mean initially i
ended it we had our season finale and
then
part of like an extended deal for
ridiculousness at that time they said
they would give me like a guaranteed
pickup of like 60 episodes if i'd commit
to another
season of fantasy factory so
ridiculousness was going at the same
time yeah so ridiculousness yeah they
were um now they're i was doing both of
them at the same time so i actually sold
them both at the same at the exact same
time they bought two shows from you had
one because originally i i read the
article like in 2007 of vinnie debona's
500 million dollar global syndication of
america's funniest home videos and was
like man like i need to make that i need
i should just make the cool version of
america's funniest home videos and i
took a one hour episode of america's
funniest home videos stripped it down to
just the good videos made a little
compilation and just had like my xbox
controller and went in and did the show
almost exactly how i do the show of like
trying to show that hey
there's like a opportunity for this type
of content at a much higher cooler pace
and so they picked them up both at the
same time but they would only pay me 30
000 for ridiculousness and they were
going to give me 125 000 per episode for
fantasy factory and i just didn't want
to do them both at the exact same time
so once we shot
with the first season of fantasy factory
then we shot ridiculousness after that
and now you know ridiculousness has
become i think that's the network it's
it's the ridiculousness
catfish and ridiculousness all the time
all day and i i was lucky enough you
invited me on and i went there and i got
to say that i was blown away by the
well-oiled machine as he said on the
last time that you know is as many
episodes as you do
he told us you shared that it's like
four percent of your
time that's correct yeah yeah so i went
in i walked in i walked right onto the
set
they said roll i was out of there it's a
half hour show
i think i was out of there in in 40
minutes wow yeah we i think that day we
it was 31 you know oh yeah yeah maybe
i'm all of them you know what i mean but
boy what an amazing guest you were man i
can't thank you and i i was wonderful
you were amazing no i was just thinking
about how good i was look at us two
humble guys getting together no i mean
have you ever had a guest like me i am
[ __ ] brilliant man look sometimes
certainly
not even joking one of the best guests
without a doubt so why didn't you ask me
back well
[Music]
you